good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast happy Monday I
know it's not the greatest news but
listen we're here for you claude's here
for you Jax is here for you turd is here
for you it's gonna be okay turd is here
yeah it's another Monday but we're here
to help you through it's going to be a
great show in Florida it's like cozy
weather today so
I'm wondering I have to ask myself the
big question I couldn't help but Wonder
should I make a chili
well I'm scarred for you know a good
amount of time before I allow another
chili in my home given beans gate last
week I mean I had experienced chili gate
back in December which kind of turned me
off to Chile for a while if you know you
know patrons will remember but it's
March and I haven't had a chili since
December I feel like I might be ready
for one
I will never discourage anyone for
making a chili you want to know why
it feeds the soul it's so nourishing
it's so nourishing
it feeds a family for quite some time
you throw it in the freezer you always
have leftovers it makes your home smell
good I'll never discourage literally any
sort of effort to make a chili yeah and
like now that I just drive every day
because I'm just like a driver I could
just go and get my ingredients
isn't that so fun like the freedom that
having a license gives you like you were
a prisoner up until this point I know I
actually might get another manicure
today because this one is chipping she's
crazy because it wasn't very good and
now I'm just gonna like have a manicure
every week again crazy you know I took
an Uber yesterday and I was chatting
with my driver lovely man and he was
really asking questions about Theo
um and he was telling me that the Tesla
it was a Tesla Uber sorry I forgot that
important fact he was telling me that
the Tesla has a dog mode so like you
know you're not supposed to leave kids
or dogs in cars alone but if you need to
run in somewhere and Bruno's with you
Tesla has a dog mode that like saves the
energy of the car but circulates the air
turns the screen off so they can't touch
anything you should check it out oh I
should that's good to know I love it
hearing like positive fun things about
the Tesla because always non-tesla
drivers are like haters Tesla's doing
this and Tesla's doing that it's like
you're just not a part of the club so
yeah no I'd be pressed too yeah no
you're hating from outside the club yeah
because so far just a little Tesla
update I've had it for a few weeks but
then it was like I had to get my charger
installed waiting for the electrician he
didn't have a part blah blah
what is with what is with nobody ever
having part nobody has the right parts
if they have whether they come to fix
the oven like anything it's like oh we
gotta order the part yeah well it's like
we brought the part but we brought the
wrong part wrong part always like where
are the parts no it's always the wrong
part but now it's been like a week of
having charger my charger is charging on
my Tesla and it's been an amazing
experience so far okay good so far I'm
so happy with my decision
I need to like oh my God something so
annoying which I'm gonna figure out it's
like you have driver profiles so like
when you come you could like set up a
little profile in the steering wheel and
the seat and the what's the other thing
the windows will be uh attuned to you
but then like it logs me out of Spotify
when I made my profile so every time I
get in the car I log into Spotify and
then every time I get in the car again
like I'm logged out and it's like I was
listening to the radio this weekend it
was all commercials it was torture and
Harry was in the car with me and he was
like Mom this is [__] this is
unacceptable I need some smooth Tunes I
was like I know he needs some smooth
jazz yeah like I don't want to be
listening to these chaotic [__] radio
commercials how is Harry I really this
is one of the longest I've gone without
seeing seeing him when was the last time
I was at your house like January
when were you at my house even January
no right before I went to LA January no
no you were here in February
okay well it still feels like a really
long time
but what were you here for in February
was it the surprise
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
the surprise week
yeah I really like I'm I'm struggling
every morning I wake up and I'm like
what if I just got on a flight what if
you just like we would love to have you
Harry would love to see you he's really
been craving antiquoia and energy
I really like um obsessed I really miss
him and Kayla needs me they all Bruno
need to Bruno needs Theo Bruno needs me
he doesn't need Theo he needs me you
know but he needs to like jockey for he
needs the competition you know he needs
to be kept on his toes he's getting a
little too comfortable and I know it's
just like he likes that rivalry every
couple of weeks like I get this itch you
know to see my family it's very normal
of me and actually my itch was
exasperated this weekend while I was so
alone I was alone all weekend and on
Friday night I was just like I should
have made plans like for when I forget
like when Ben's out of town I'm always
like oh it'll be nice I'll have the
place to myself and I'll read and take a
bath I'm like you know I never do that
either take a bath and then what like 15
minutes yeah
and I spiral and like on Friday night I
was so lonely like next level lonely
um and then I opened my phone and like
you and Olivia are like having a
barbecue and we're outside and the kids
Zach's flipping burgers and I was like
these people are disgusting and I like
was spy relaying on Friday night you
want to know how desperate I got I
started to watch Daisy Jones in the six
that should tell you everything you need
to know and were we right well you know
I hated that book like and everyone
loved it I hated it and comparatively to
the book I'm enjoying the show more I
don't think it's very good I think um
there's some really good moments from it
like I think Cami Marone is a star like
the show is and in the book her
character you're like you kind of hate
her because you're like she's The Other
Woman you know yeah she's like this
she's like this obstacle but in the show
she's like the Cornerstone of the band
like she's the glue and she's such a
good actress I don't think I've ever
seen her anything and this is definitely
like a major breakout role for her she's
excellent Suki Waterhouse who plays
Karen the drummer he or no keyboard
she's incredible a lot of people were
saying that Suki Waterhouse should have
dyed her hair red and been cast as Daisy
because she's really like electric but
the two main stars Billy Dunn and Daisy
Jones I am enormously disappointed in I
think I don't know if it's Riley Keough
or like the way that they created the
daisy Jones character but in the book
Daisy Jones is like this wild electric
red hair like everyone is drawn to her
she's like this wild girl and she like
you know she wins people over with her
electricity right she's electric yeah
but she's also like the most beautiful
the most talented like voices like Silk
you know none of that is coming through
like whatsoever I don't know if we're
supposed to like Daisy she seems like
kind of off I don't know if it's bad
acting I don't know if it's bad
character development from like the show
in the script it's not good the
character and then Billy is so miscast
he's so old everyone it's supposed to be
like these young crazy kids he looks 45
um I don't think he's classically
handsome enough for the role he's
supposed to be this like All-American
rock star young kid not working
um so the two main characters are kind
of like flopping and I think some of the
supplemental people in the band who are
kind of Irrelevant in the book are
really carrying the show I'm only on
episode five it's not great it's fine I
think a lot of people are liking it who
like loved the book and just are excited
to see the book come to life and in a
lot of ways the visuals of the TV show
are kind of how I pictured the book you
know they're living in this house
together La you know 60s Laurel Canyon
Hollywood Hills they did get a lot of
the ascent Aesthetics it's not hard to
get right like it was very clear what it
was in the book um but it's not great
it's not great that sounds exactly like
I expected I I didn't find the casting
to be
[Applause]
Riley Keough being Elvis's granddaughter
is not enough to carry her in this role
like it it's a it's like it's exciting
and it adds another element of like rock
and roll
but it's not enough no I didn't think so
either it's just like it wasn't right no
and a lot of people were saying Miley
Cyrus should have been Daisy Jones and
you know what I really could see it
that's good yeah because I said on my
stories I like wasn't thrilled with how
it turned out and people were like well
who do you want to be Daisy Jones like
I'm complaining come up with a better
solution and I didn't have any but then
people started suggesting what they
thought and a lot of people said Miley
Cyrus oh my God for sure because she
really is at her core an actress a lot
of people know when she is that like
Stevie Nicks Vibe that's really why
she's branded herself is like a modern
you know she's always covering like Joan
Jett yeah but she that's Daisy Jones and
the six is meant to be like Stevie Nicks
and Fleetwood Mac Miley yeah no it was a
really good call damn that's so annoying
when that happens it's like you [__]
up and it's too late I will say though
the song that's like you know the song
there's a bunch of songs but there's the
one honeycomb I'm really enjoying oh
really like but if we get here and
working now it's a really good song it
does really sound like Fleetwood Mac
damn that I would be like I'm sad to
miss out on like good music and the show
that's like a musical show is good
not only do I not have the time even if
I did it's so far down on the list you
wouldn't like it you might not like this
no I saw the trailer and I was like I
actually liked the book and this doesn't
look like a show I would enjoy yeah
um but I that is like a
A Plus in their column that song is so
good I think Marcus Mumford wrote it
Marcus Mumford and maren Morris that
makes sense how did we get here I don't
know the words but every time it comes
on because it's like it's the song that
blew them up I'm always like in my bed
with the shoulder and Tano of a date
saying on it now it's good that's good
that's really reassuring
and because I was so bored I also
watched um something I've been wanting
to do for a while 1923 one of the
Yellowstone prequels I didn't watch like
the 1883 I should watch them in
chronological order but like it doesn't
really matter
um have you seen it no okay I won't
spoil anything it's good it's good you
know I like Yellowstone better
um love to see Michelle Randolph out
there shaking her thing what a beauty
yeah what a beauty she's perfect for the
role she's supposed to be this like
young wild like beautiful girl and she's
crazy for it yeah literally
um it's good I
I don't know why I'm like five episodes
in and I still have to reference the
family tree they're making it so
complicated for who is who like and
who's who's the son and who's the uncle
and who's the daughter it is so
[__] confusing
damn I had to screenshot the family tree
and I'm referencing it every episode
got it got it I haven't seen it yet and
realistically I probably am not going to
watch just because of like timing and
life and life happens and I never
finished 1886 just because of life like
1883. I liked it when I was watching it
but apparently not enough to finish it
that's the barometer like oh it's good
but I didn't finish it so was it really
ever that no and it's like I know they
they do make it to Montana and they put
down roots and they have a long
illustrious life there so I Know How It
Ends
um so that is what I watched this
weekend most of the time I was on my
phone stalking the eras Tour opening
night which is why I'm wearing my Taylor
sweatshirt today from the bar
um so I'm on the bar PR list but I
didn't get the Taylor sweatshirt and
this isn't me like saying it so that I
get them because like it's okay but it's
like is Bridget enough of a toaster to
know that like I'm not that you're kind
of a hater no I'm literally not a hater
I'm no you're not a hater I'm kidding
I'm just like a normal fan I love
Taylor's music I listen to her albums
backwards and forwards I've actually
listened to midnights like way more than
you I'm obsessed with it and I've been a
fan since the beginning of her career I
just like yes have a head on my
shoulders and I have this I'm not a
toxic Swifty and they have a career and
like I just have things that you know I
keep me busy and then I listen to music
you know yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um you have those things too yet you
have chosen I prioritize Taylor you have
chosen this life of Swifty hood and you
know what you like to be a part of
something I do and it was fun I know I
said I was like I'm not gonna spoil it
whatever and you know what like [__]
that like I feel like every time I go to
a concert I've seen a million videos I
know I look up the set list before so
it's like not a spoiler I mean it was
very exciting on Friday night like I was
glued to my phone the swifties were
working tirelessly on Tick Tock live
Instagram live they kept getting taken
down they were going back up I watched
about the first hour of the show and
then because it was Pacific time I got
tired um and then throughout the weekend
I just kept watching videos so I'm aware
of like the setlist the outfits I don't
think it's going to ruin the magic of
when we go for the first time I if
anything it got me even more excited it
looked amazing and so randomly like I
couldn't really put into words like my
thoughts until I saw this video that JJ
Watt did
um I guess him his wife is a big Swifty
and they all went like a bunch of
friends him and his wife and he made
this video afterwards just like really
saying how impressed he was with the
show and this is coming from an athlete
who like you know is in amazing shape
and he was like I was in awe you know
three hours of non-stop she didn't stop
for one second singing she didn't stop
for one second dancing Taylor's not one
of those artists who like you know
during the popular part of the song will
let the crowd sing no she was on point
the entire time doing the choreography
doing the singing doing the entertaining
she had like two outfits sorry she had
like 10 outfit changes and those each
took like a minute so she didn't really
get any time off and JJ Watt was just
like so impressed with how you know even
towards the end she was still giving it
100 she didn't even look to be a little
tired and how impressive that was and
it's so true she did a three hour and 15
minute show 44 songs and she gave it her
all and it it was perfectly put and I I
felt the exact same way and then I also
just loved like the randomness of JJ
Watt and then JJ Watt was stuck in my
brain the entire day I had a dream last
night that JJ Watt got the snatchler
pregnant
like they're so happy together like I'm
not saying anything but it was just like
in my dream
damn
um I just had so many questions for you
about that what you saw I saw some
things too it looked amazing like I saw
the breakdown of how many songs in every
era there were some that were more some
that were less but like it was good for
Taylor did what was good for Taylor what
felt true to Taylor are there any like
famous swifties
you mean famous people who are swifties
or swifties who have become famous
swifties who have become famous for
being swifties there are a few right now
I would say like one of the more famous
swifties is the guy who invented the
Bejeweled dance okay um and he did it's
like it was like kind of a weird dance
um but then everyone just like started
doing and it became like the dance of
Bejeweled and Taylor's choreography
included that dance so I don't know if
he worked with her or he's probably
gonna get to meet her what do you mean
worked with her it's just walking and
turning yeah but like at so like it is
someone's choreography and like you do
have to like you know acknowledge that I
don't even know if you have to pay them
for using their choreography by the way
okay no it is a thing like lizzo no it
is a thing but that particular
choreography that's the choreography the
most low and it is the most low energy
Tick Tock dance of all the tick tock
dances it doesn't matter somebody's it's
still somebody's original idea and so
Taylor I'm sure she's like I'm sure in
general she reached out to the person
who came up like with the dance for her
song to make it viral but I'm just
saying like taking a few steps and
spinning around like no I'm I know what
you're saying but I'm saying it's still
someone's original choreography like
whatever however low energy and like
minimal it is
okay
um so I would say right now he's the
most famous Swifty I think his name is
Michael he was freaking
um but yes you know I think it comes in
waves because now Taylor's very much in
her Tick Tock era and like the famous
swifties are on Tick Tock whereas before
they used to be on Tumblr
got it so now people are um like getting
noticed on on Tick Tock yeah I follow
this girl Catherine she's like this
really cute high schooler like I'm
actually she's so like she's just like
so normal like she's like like lives in
a house that's like it literally looks
like it's like a Netflix show like when
they just like try and put like a
regular teenager like that's when like
regular teenagers look like and she's so
cute and she made up a dance um and she
has like a lot of tick tock followers
exclusively as a Swifty right that's
what I'm saying like and but people who
used to get invited to like the red
living room what is it called it was
reputation room but also the listening
parties yeah like are those people still
like you know well you know active and
they are but the people back in the day
who used to get invited to those like
secret sessions and stuff they were not
famous swifties they were just very
loyal consistent users on social media
about Taylor so it wasn't even like a
Fame thing right but like now if they
got that opportunity of such an
opportunity existed like they would go
viral on Tick Tock and then they'd be
like famous 50s but she there is no I
mean it's a literally a three and a half
hour show I don't know how she could
then do like a midnight I hope she's not
doing meet and greets that she's not um
she didn't in Arizona so I don't know if
she's going to but at the present point
she's not no I I appreciate her
prioritizing like more music more songs
over meet and greets yeah and so she
really did her absolute best to include
as many songs as possible 44 is an
insane amount of songs she shortened
some songs so we get like you know more
songs we don't need the whole song she
goes you know from the first chorus into
the bridge but what a lot I think you
know the major takeaway from this
weekend is like it's the era's tour
she's acknowledging all of her eras we
never got like a lover or an Ever more
folklore tour so she really does like
big chunks of that which I'm really
grateful for she opens with lover
because it was supposed to be the next
tour after reputation
um but she does one song from speak now
she didn't chanted and then literally
changed into her red outfit which was
like so crazy to so many people
um she also didn't doesn't do any songs
from debut the first night she did Tim
McGraw and then I think a lot of people
thought it was going to be like that one
song from debut but the next night it
turned out Tim McGraw was one of those
interchangeable songs there's two
changes that two songs that changed from
the setlist every week
um but I am confused like I know Taylor
does everything for a reason like she it
was a choice to do one song from
Enchanted especially I mean excuse me
one song from speak now especially when
there's so many iconic songs from speak
now including Long Live which is very
much like the anthem of her whole brand
do you think it's because she doesn't
own the rights to those songs and maybe
she has to pay someone to use it and
she's not going to pay but currently she
doesn't own 1989 and she still did a big
1989 because I was trying to think which
others haven't been re-recorded so it's
debut speak now in 1989. still haven't
been recorded yeah but she did a lot
from 1989. yeah
huh
it's like you know everything Taylor
does is intentional I just want to see
what else what's the reason I want to
see what else is on speak now to see if
there's other any glaring I mean Back to
December no it's just a story about I
see sparks fly whenever you smile hit me
with those green nuts Long Live yeah
there's a lot here there's a lot there
huh it's a choice
I hate Back to December
I like it I said what I said it's like
one of the it's probably like one of the
only songs I've written I don't you know
what song I hate that I was confusing
with mine
oh what's wrong with that I just don't
like it okay
um I like Back to December it's one of
the I would say the only song that
Taylor's written about a former lover
who's positive that's complimentary and
you know what makes Taylor Lautner look
like such a good guy I can't believe I
forgot to ask him that when I
interviewed him I'm a [__] [__]
charity low don't we're stopping the
negative self-talk add it to the list of
regrets oh my gosh we can't get that
minute
no it's a big regretto maybe it's for a
reason like maybe maybe it's like a
thing between like Taylor it's not it's
not because his wife Tay lotner is like
a Swifty she actually made a tick tock
this weekend like when you're not the
only tailor he's dated like she's funny
about it like it's clearly like
something we can talk about and I'm just
the [__] who forgot yeah who dropped
the ball for for The Toasters I
apologize and the swifties right they're
less forgiving
beyond the toasters
you're our turdy Lou you can't do any
wrong and I did actually leave the house
this weekend once to go to an influencer
Gathering a gathering of influencers
were you the influencer mentor I was the
influencer mentor
um it was Remy Bader's birthday party
which are it's always fun I went last
year and it was really fun and this year
was fun too but she always has a theme
and it's always themes like I cannot get
on board with like last year was
Euphoria and like what the [__] am I
gonna wear to a Euphoria themed party
you know how picky I am with what I
choose to put on my body you don't want
to wear like your nipples out right
later everywhere no and the influencers
like love the Euphoria theme so like
everyone looked amazing and I looked
literally stupid
um and then this year was Denim and
Diamonds and I vowed like not to look
stupid but it was just as hard for me to
come up denim has anyone in this room
ever seen me wear like blue denim
no no
and you know everyone you know had these
cute Denim sets and I went shopping I
tried and everything I ordered I really
ordered this incredibly cute item from
nastiel shout out nasty yell for
literally having the worst shipping ever
I paid 25 like Forex it's still not here
yeah and I ordered it on time like I
ordered it like a week and a half ago
okay but you looked amazing so sorry for
you what happened I you know I'm always
always praising this brand and yet again
show me your MooMoo out here with the
best customer service the best
everything
um there was this denim I was on revolve
and there was this denim jumpsuit and it
was sold out in all the sizes on
revolved so they had it on their website
I did two-day shipping I got it in a
couple sizes I just returned the sizes
that didn't work
um and I was like kind of uncomfortable
it was definitely like a something I
would never wear because it was like
skin tight form-fitting form-fitting and
one thing about me like I'm always gonna
wear something baggy it's just how I
feel always going to cover your form I
am always going to cover my form
especially the form of my belly like
maybe I'll risk it with like a tight
pant or a tight sleeve I'll never wear a
tight belly item it's just not how I was
raised it's not
um but I did because I had no other
options and I actually thought it looked
pretty good and I felt really good in
the outfit and I'm glad that I took the
risk because I was on theme I liked the
look and it was a successful day of
stepping out of your comfort zone
add it to the list updos showing your
arms form fitting who is you have not
you have not been telling me to before
no no no not it's a different list
um oh oh it's a list of things
no no you know what the list is things
turdy's doing in her saying yes to life
era yeah turdy's my life in 2021 I never
would have done oh sorry no oh my God
2022. yeah yeah no that's different from
like I didn't say it was with like
reading in Downton oh this whole time I
thought you were no that's a difference
reading Downton updos arms out is one
list you were not telling me to put my
arms out ever oh no no I I wouldn't
share no really even up to up to oh wait
I'm always saying put your hair up like
no you're doing it up to but you weren't
really trying ever oh my God always
trying to get you and Margaret to wear
your [__] hair up always okay okay oh
and on the show too I'm sure someone
could roll it back some clips roll the
tapes and then this is a separate list
of turdy's New Life okay okay thank you
for explaining the lists I've got a lot
of lists and I'm checking and you're
checking it twice yeah to take the doors
down gonna find out if turds naughty or
nice I could tell you turd's naughty as
[__] because not to be that girl you
don't have your period I got it this
morning and oh my God I was joking you
just had it
a month ago I know you'd like been
pregnant for 100 years but like we are
getting our periods every month you know
okay I can't believe that was a month
ago time flies when you're getting your
period no I know and like you're by the
way you just said a mouthful there
sister it's so true
um you're just like kind of privileged
that like in the last two years you only
had a couple periods yeah and some of us
are out here you know cramping it up
once a month some of us are you know
experiencing the joys of pregnancy and
all the aches and pains that accompany
it but sure sure
so I was saying this morning like I know
I'm going to be in like a [__] mood
on the toast but I'm feeling better but
it was a rough morning like it was it
was a journey to get to where I am now
damn it's how I chose that sweatshirt I
literally knew you're so [__]
predictable like are you you're in your
red era
and you're the one who doesn't like when
people talk about their periods and
you're being very descriptive well
that's that's true but now we said it so
the floodgates are opened literally
[Laughter]
mind talking about periods sometimes
like you have to talk about periods but
like I just aside from you because we do
a Daily Show and it's Jermaine actually
to your presence people are like wow
Claudia was in a mood today and it's
like well you know what my biology is
working against me like I think it's
important that everybody has
context I have really no issue with you
sharing but there are other influencers
who it's like why do I know you're my
menstrual cycles no but Jackie like the
way I was never in my life like eager or
really felt like I had any urge to talk
about my period but ever since you said
that now I find myself talking about it
all the time do you think it's because
like you're one you're you're either
trying to like you know hurt you get me
uncomfortable because like we love to do
that we do push me on my comfort zone or
is it just that now that I've said it
we're noticing it it's probably that
um but on a day like today like I did
feel like bringing it up because if I'm
at all Snappy or quick with you and the
audience is like what's up Claudia has
asked today a tampon okay that's what's
up my ass I guess you never learned how
to properly use one
um okay okay pray for me
but also that's fine if you're feeling
negative Vibes coming for me today which
I'm gonna try and battle my you know
Natural Instinct just know like it's not
my fault it's literally nature okay
okay
so I just I think context is important
thank you for that and so welcome now we
should embark on the job of delivering
the fast five stories that you need to
know
while avoiding as much negativity as
possible yeah that's today's mission
and today's mission is brought to you
very appropriately by liquid IV if
you're trying to improve your health
hydration is a great place to start and
liquid IV is a hydration brand that
fuels your well-being you know in my
year of yes liquid IV has been a huge
part of it I now have like one or two
packs in my purse at all time
for hangovers when I'm traveling for
just like General fatigue and
dehydration when I'm traveling it's a
great thing to always have in your purse
so their hydration multiplier which is
what I throw in my purse is the one
product that you're missing out on in
your daily routine it's a great low lift
Wellness tip that's what we were talking
about last week in just one stick you
get five essential vitamins and two
times faster hydration than water alone
use it first thing in the morning before
a workout when you feel run down after a
long night out and on Long flights a lot
of what I do is on a long flight after a
long night out or just when I'm not
feeling good it's so good to have in
your purse and again I'm all about low
lift Wellness tips and drinking like 16
ounces of water is pretty low lift so
one stick of liquid IV into 16 ounces of
water hydrates you two times faster and
more efficiently than water alone it
contains vitamin B3 B5 B6 B12 and C it's
made with premium ingredients it's
non-GMO free from gluten dairy and soy
and it has three times the electrolytes
of a traditional sports drink so grab
your liquid IV in bulk you can get it
nationwide at Costco or you can get 20
off when you go to liquid iv.com and use
the code toast at checkout that's 20 off
anything you order when you shop better
hydration today using promo code toast
at liquid iv.com again that's promo code
toast today's episode is also brought to
you by Squarespace
so from websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business so whether you have a
side hustle e-commerce business you work
in e-commerce you want to build a
website whatever it is that you're doing
check out Squarespace because it's
really easy to get a website up and
running and you don't have to have like
a huge background in software
engineering check out squarespace.com
toast for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch use the offer code toast
to save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or a domain so here's some of
the great things about Squarespace
whether you work in e-commerce it is the
place to sell anything they have the
tools you need to get your business off
the ground including e-commerce
templates Inventory management a simple
checkout process and secure payments
whatever you sell Squarespace has
merchandising features to make your
products look their best online they
also offer content ownership so you own
all the content you put on the
Squarespace platform they offer a
one-click data portability they give you
great insights into your traffic
overview so see how your visits unique
visitors page views are trending over
time time you'll gain insight into the
top traffic sources products device
types browsers operating systems really
detailed analytics that can help you run
your business better they also help you
do email campaigns collect donations
share on social blogging tools so
whatever you're coming to square coming
to Squarespace for
um in terms of building a website they
will have features that will really
really help you so again go to
squarespace.com toast for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch use
offer code toast to save 10 off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
thank you Claudia what can I say except
get welcome for all the links and all
the codes that'll save our first story
Ariana Maddox has made our first public
appearance since scandaval oh she took
the stage Saturday night at a wacky
comedy show at the Upright Citizens
Brigade Theater in LA because you know
she takes such comedy seriously and you
know who else takes sketch comedy
seriously Upright Citizens Brigade
that's like a legit troop Yes except
what they were doing did not seem very
serious
um and it wasn't like sketch comedy but
it was like a sandwich making
competition with Ariana and fibula
I love fibulan fabula listens to the
toast so yeah yeah yeah shout out shout
out uh so she took the stage at the
venue just a few minutes away from
Schwartz and Sandy's and eyewitness told
page six that the reality star was met
with Thunders cheers and Applause from
the crowd when she walked on stage at
the live event build is the only
sandwich-making game show on the planet
they said from the smile on her face and
little Dan she did while walking out on
stage she appeared a little surprised
but super appreciative of all the fans
support and judging from the audience's
excitement it was evident that the
majority of people showed up to see her
she looked carefree and seemed to be
having a good time there was no mention
of the scandal of course
um and the show was called make that
sandwich and it was her and fibula
competing to make sandwiches I'm sure
like a part of it was also like doing
Improv
yeah
um I just want to say something like a
takeaway I've had from this whole
situation is like
Ariana's really like not thirsty I think
like if you think about anyone else who
was like put in this position where like
the entire fan base and the entire world
has like learned about your situation
and it's like riding for you like they
would be posting so much on Instagram
and like doing events or like maybe
interviews like there's a way you could
really thirst out and like capitalize on
this moment and the fact that Ariana has
like been seen twice one at a friend's
wedding and one at like this like small
improv sketch comedy thing like it makes
me have a lot of respect for her like
she's not thirsting out on this moment
yes but don't you feel like everyone
else is everyone all of her friends are
yes and she's given them she's giving
them permission to talk about everything
but like I just think it's so weird not
the talking and giving interviews to
other podcasters and of course everyone
has a podcast and they're doing all
these different like permutations of
like K uh Sheena and Kristen right
Sheena has a podcast
this one Justin Dodie has a podcast yeah
and they're all like you know
and talking about it but then like
Lala's selling merch about it and it
just feels so weird to me no I agree and
I don't like I'm I stand firmly on team
Ariana even like Sheena did her episode
and for a few days it was only available
on patreon and then it dropped to the
public and it's important to note like
if I had been in this situation like I
would very much probably be doing the
same like you know as a reality star
slash influencer like moments like this
is like what you make your your living
on
um but these are your best friend's
trauma these are friends like this is a
group of friends and I agree like the
level of Fame and like the non-stop
stories from the cast members like it's
kind of crazy it's kind of crazy and
it's it's crazy that like it doesn't
borrow their Ariana whatsoever because I
don't think that it does and I think
that if it did for one second they
wouldn't they would stop they have
express permission to go all the way
with everything and like I just
it's it's crazy to me it just feels a
little weird to me I agree
um especially because a lot of them are
limited in what they can share because
of their contracts like Bravo doesn't
want all this tea being built on
podcasts they want it to save it for the
show and that's why a lot of people are
loving Chris and Dodie's podcast because
she doesn't she's very much at the
center of this but she doesn't have a
contract she can say whatever the [__]
she wants and that's why her episode on
file files and her own podcast like blew
up in the way that they did because
there's no red tape around what she can
say but I'm sure also there's things
that she's not saying because she is
filming again like I don't think she
wants to piss them off expressly but she
definitely has more flexibility than the
other cast members but I I agree it's
it's a kind of out of hand
yeah and
it's just like
I don't know at a certain point it's
kind of like rubbing me the wrong way no
I know and I don't know if it's like the
effects of last week when I was so
turned off on the episode by everyone
except rockelle
um and now like the behavior is just
starting I'm starting to be like well
well I don't know because like I and I
don't want this to be misconstrued like
I stand firmly on team Ariana I just
think the behavior a lot of a lot of the
other girls is questionable yeah I agree
but no when it comes to this like it's
oh there's only a team Ariana and the
fact that they're we are going to say
team Ariana it's like well there's duh
there's no there's not a
this isn't a match like there's one team
where there's not even a team Tom no
that would literally consist of Tom
yeah
but it's curious yeah it's curious but
I'm really glad that she's doing well
that she was out and about she changed
her hair color to be like even lighter
it looks great oh it's like more
platinum blonde and it looks she looks
awesome so okay good yeah
are you ready for our next story yeah
more clarity in all the law roach
retirement drama because law roach sat
down for an interview with the cut and
like answered a bunch of questions it
was like q a style and he's talking
about his career talking about the
retirement specifically like what that
means what led him to that point and
there were some interesting nuggets from
the interview I appreciate that he like
made this big splash and didn't just
disappear with all these questions like
oh you guys are unclear let me do a
follow-up yeah like because in the
interview he's like when did I post that
two days ago so like literally he must
have gotten his current he must have
gotten so much press Outreach and he was
like yeah I'll sit down with the cut and
explain what happened so he
um kind of talks about how he
got to this place after Oscar's week and
building up to the Vanity Fair Oscars
party he said it's some of the most
stressful times in the world and I've
been a stylist that did multiple clients
so I'm trying to prepare for multiple
clients that week he said he had a lot
of pressure from Megan the stallion
because it was her first time coming
back and anybody seeing her since the
trial and so that was a lot of pressure
you know because I wanted to make her
feel secure and comfortable make her
feel and look as perfect as possible so
that she can have the strength to do
what she had to do so that morning I got
a call from one of my clients and it was
her her publicist and somebody from a
brand that I'm supposed to do the
project with and I found myself on the
phone with these three women I felt like
I was defending myself because the one
woman from the brand was like oh he's
not communicating and you're not going
to have the dress and all these things
and it was just a lot of things that
were not true and that's how we lose
clients as stylists somebody from a
brand will say something to the
publicist then the publicist will say
something to the client and then it's
this thing I thought I had a really
strong relationship with this client and
I thought she knew that my goal is
always to protect my clients and at that
moment I just didn't feel like I was
being protected because there's no one
who can ever say that they've worked
with me that I didn't put my whole heart
and soul into them or that I left them
hanging and they didn't have a dress
it's never happened no one can ever say
that about me
he said that call was very early the
next day
um after the Oscars and the client was
one of the clients that I dressed that
night oh this is another call like more
Oscars [__] politics right but he's
not saying though that like Meg the
stallion is the person he's referring to
like these politics what he is saying is
like there are all these Gatekeepers
that gate keep the client it's publicist
it's agents managers all of these people
who come in between him and the client
to like facilitate the relationship and
there's a few things that happen a few
issues that he's encountered one like
he's never The Stylist that they go to
when someone wants a stylist they have
like a list of people that they would
encourage you to work with and he's
never like being put forward by The
Gatekeepers he calls them two he said he
likes to have a personal relationship
with his clients these people don't let
you you know they are the ones doing the
scheduling they'll they say oh so and so
you know they don't ever let really let
you like interface with their client
yeah and that's not how he likes to work
he also said there's like people who say
about him like oh if you work with him
you're just gonna get all the clothes in
day it didn't want but by the way he
said that's obviously not true he
doesn't walk around with a suitcase full
of Zendaya's cast offs but honestly some
of you people would look better in
Zendaya's cast-offs than what you're
wearing no please give me the [__]
beneath Zendaya's shoe and look better
than what I'm wearing today like like
yeah
runner-up Oscars sure oh my God today I
liked it but didn't like it enough good
enough for you give me like her fifth
Choice yeah yeah no you know what's
interesting it's like about celebrity
Dynamics it's like the way that it's
built you know to have like an agent a
manager a publicist a lawyer business
manager all these people around really
to protect you when working with Brands
when working with Studios
and so the system works but it doesn't
really work with stylus because I think
and anyone who you know has ever worked
with a stylist probably would agree that
like I think uh the most beneficial like
relationships between stylists and
celebrities are those that are so close
like Zendaya and law like they're
friends like you get to know the person
you can dress them better it's like it
benefits everyone when there's a
closeness and it's so collaborative
right you don't need to be close when
working with a brand they're paying you
for a service like the manager should
protect you from those types like I get
that but a stylist I wouldn't equate
with like working like a movie studio
you need that closeness in order to
really get it you know you get to
understand what the person you know what
their hopes and dreams are what their
insecurities are like it's more
beneficial for everyone when The Stylist
really really knows you and it's not
impersonal yeah and I think that's how
he works best he was even saying when
someone like reaches out to him he does
like a whole Google search of everything
they've ever worn to like try and get an
understanding of the person so having
these people in the way like that's the
politics and [__] he was talking
about so pretty much he said that he'll
still be working with Zendaya and then
all of like he said like clients reached
out to him when he posted that and
pretty much being like well what about
me right and he's like you're able to
find a new stylist all's good with him
and today he explained the Louis Vuitton
thing yeah I saw his explanation and you
know what it it did make a lot of sense
he said that he always sits next to
Zendaya because they like you know watch
the show together and they pick together
the sorts of things that they like so he
got there there wasn't a seat next to
her for him and she pointed behind her
because she was saying this is um her
assistant seat so he was saying that one
no like I think just to say like it was
available but it wasn't her saying you
sit here no no no no no no so he said
all's good between them which he did say
last week and now he's focusing on he's
gonna be announced as like the creative
director of a footwear brand soon wait
but also back to the Louis Vuitton thing
I thought his explanation in terms of
like context was really helpful and
important because this was the first
show Zendaya went to of Louis Vuitton as
one of the faces of Louis Vuitton and
their previous partnership I'm not
entirely sure what brand he was
referencing Zendaya was the one and only
face of that brand so when they would go
to shows it was like set in stone it was
her and law sitting front row but this
is the first time that they went to a
show of the brand that Zendaya is
working with that has a lot of faces
it's not like the Zendaya show anymore
so it was just a new Dynamic and he
wasn't mad he was they just didn't know
yet like there was no president out of a
previous show so I think that like much
many things that go viral on Tick Tock
like that video
context has nothing to do with the
retirement announcement it really sounds
like it was Oscar's Vanity Fair Mayhem
the politics after years of this
no and it makes sense like celebrity
Dynamics are so [__] yeah and
especially like there are so many people
like around celebrities who seek to
protect them but also really just
isolate them like yeah I feel like I
understand why they have to have some
people to you know interface with the
studio interface like uh-huh it's a lot
for the celebrity but like this
this can talk to some people you know
they don't need to be completely managed
they're still adults and they're human
beings and they're working business
people like
well I guess it depends on the celebrity
I think a lot of celebrities like
actually do need to be managed but a lot
of them are yes like these uh oh running
of an Empire like you could pick out
your own dress yeah and you can like
talk to people I think there are a
couple celebrities who
are not well but most of them are like
functioning adults
so but some of them like those layers of
protection like some of them put those
in place for that reason yes but then
like you know you're gonna just get sent
a bunch of dresses that have nothing to
do with you right right
so I'm really the interview was very
wide-ranging I would recommend reading
it if you want more also stories like
he's literally was giving me he's
dropping names instances
um he talked about how one star had dmed
him about wanting to work with him
because she had a movie coming out and
she didn't like you know some of the
stylists that were suggested to her by
her teams and I was feeling like it was
Addison
oh I just like that's just a Vibe I got
oh and did he say it was a client he now
worked with
um he said it was like a
a client one of hold on let me find the
so a current client and that would be he
said so sometimes what happens is
Italian will just DM me hey would you
work with me can we talk about this I
started working with this client she had
a really big movie coming out and she
said you know I want to be a fashion
girl I want to take risks and there's
nobody else I want to work with but you
like totally Addison because she's like
a digital girly DM like she had events
before yeah but it wasn't until I feel
like it was like he's all that yeah
no by the way that's a really good call
yeah so he's just like well as much tea
as you like would hope for
without I love someone who's direct like
direct like he made this big drama on
Instagram and I think a lot of annoying
people would have just like walked away
you know lit the fire and bounced oh and
he's like oh you guys have follow-up
questions let me sit down for an
interview and drop names and and people
yeah like even though even talking about
like Mega the Sally and how like he
dressed her and there was a lot of
pressure for her to like look amazing
and the way that things went South had
absolutely nothing to do with her but
great now I can start to imagine as
opposed to him being like I had a client
who was a really big Knight for them
right and you know what I mean no and
actually I I actually really appreciated
him sharing his thought process for you
know the importance of dressing Megan
the stallion that night and it actually
makes me feel like he's a really good
stylist because I hadn't even thought
about how like how big of a deal this
was like first public appearance since
the trial and he honestly seems like an
empath like he actually really cares he
said that not not just like oh this
dress looks good on you walk out the
door but like there's meaning behind it
and this is a person who dealt with
something like really traumatizing and I
want to make them feel beautiful and
actually like that sharing that anecdote
like actually really makes me like him
even more he said that he's a huge
empath and that's why it's particularly
draining for for him when he gives so
much like of himself to his clients and
then there's these people who just like
tear it down ruin it yeah yeah so
I love that we got a like a full circle
moment on this thank you but that he
truly is retiring from celebrity style
the celebrity yeah yeah
damn damn are you ready for our next
story yeah Shawn Mendes has addressed
this Sabrina Carpenter dating rumors
yeah I know in like a rude way yeah
Shawn Mendes she's being very short
he shut down online speculation that he
and Sabrina Carpenter are dating boo My
article won't load just give me one
second
well I can give you guys like a little
context they were photographed together
a few weeks ago thanks turdy definitely
like Jax and I were looking like does
this look like two people who are dating
they really are a good match we were
very much here for it and then he did an
interview and he was like kind of
annoyed that he was asked the question
because I think he was there to promote
something else Ralph Lauren right yes
Tommy Hilfiger literally same thing uh
he was doing an interview with a Dutch
TV program called RTL Boulevard and he
said we are not dating he then suggested
that they talk about his partnership
with Tommy Hilfiger quote probably more
than Sabrina but thank you yeah like he
was rude he literally said good day sir
I said good day
uh I'm annoyed that they're not dating
because I do think it's a really good
match and Shawn Mendes like definitely
took some time off and he came back
recently like with a buzz cut and he
gained like 15 pounds of muscle and my
God he's looking so hot like he's even
more attractive than he was before which
is crazy to think about
um and I would have loved that for
Sabrina Carpenter honestly but do you
feel like maybe they were like
hanging out a little bit and now
Sabrina's seeing this and it's like oh
I guess we're not like not they probably
weren't dating exclusively or anything
but like why do you have to say it like
that you know he like had an attitude
couldn't he have been like every other
celebrity like coin tight-lipped like I
don't like I'm not talking about that or
anything yeah yeah no he had like a mug
and an attitude and I didn't appreciate
it I just feel like if there was
anything brewing between them like we're
not going to be seeing them together
anymore just because like that was
[__] rude yeah no it's over
it was a very like terse so by the way
they were spotted together like twice in
one week they were had that like date
and sweat and also they left a party
together
so like we're not crazy for thinking
that they might be dating they're
literally so perfect and age-appropriate
yeah and cute like
I feel like Sabrina might have thought
there was something there there was
something there that wasn't there before
it literally wasn't a crazy question
like good for this interview or for
going there it would have been my first
question as well who gives a [__] about
Ralph Lauren it tell me he'll figure it
wasn't a crazy question it was a crazy
response it wasn't a great question it
was crazy results
like and especially I feel like Shawn
Mendes is like Peach I'm energy like
maybe he's on his period because he was
giving like you know
I'm rare yeah I'm just like I'm feeling
for Sabrina today because I feel like
that he made really clear that was
definitely tough way to find out like
the guy he went on a date with like
wasn't as into it as you are yeah you
just have to say like oh yeah you know
we're friends she's so awesome nobody
like I love Sabrina she's such a great
girl I love spending time with her
period yeah and then like we would now
be sitting here being like what does it
mean and instead we're being here like
oh Shawn Mendes is kind of a prick yeah
and we're like all right never mind like
the ship just crashed yeah and burned
I'm off I'm I'm jumping overboard she
deserves better she deserves someone
who's gonna speak glowingly about her in
interviews a hundred percent and I'm so
looking forward to the day where like
we're talking about Sabrina Carpenter's
relationship and it's not Joshua Bassett
like loserville and it's not Shawn
Mendes being mean like when is this girl
gonna get what she deserves yeah it's
coming Sabrina don't you worry don't
give up no Sabrina you don't chase you
attract what is yours we'll find you
Sabrina there's a lid for every pot so
true and you have a gorgeous pot Sabrina
that anyone would want to cover Sabrina
Buster murdaugh has a girlfriend okay
don't lose hope Journey Lou
I have two more stories in both I could
segue so good right now oh that's too
bad because I have something to say so
your Segways my Segways have crashed and
burned like Sean and Sabrina love that
for you our next two stories are brought
to you by Hulu's new show up here up
here is a musical series rom-com about
two characters Lindsay and Miguel
juggling career and crushes as they try
to find love in New York City in 1989.
it features original music up here as a
rom-com all about falling in love
discovering the greatest obstacle to
finding happiness together is yourself
well yourself in the treacherous world
of obsession fears memories and
Fantasies it premieres on Hulu March
24th and it's from the director of
Hamilton the screenwriter of tick Tick
boom and the songwriters of the Book of
Mormon and one division so that's Thomas
kale from Hamilton Stephen Levinson from
Tick Tick boom and Kristen and Bobby
Lopez from The Book of Mormon and Wanda
Vision it's a story about two characters
Lindsay and Miguel trying to find love
in the big city it is a story about the
opinions of friends and family and how
they manifest as voices in our heads up
here take those voices of Family and
friends and shoves them into the daily
lives of these everyday New Yorkers it's
filled with raunch and Ridiculousness up
here is about that magical time in your
life when you had nothing figured out
and all the Time in the World to think
about it so I love a musical a musical
and it's spring spring is upon us
because it it launches March 24th so the
spring musical launches March 24th on
Hulu check it out it's got really good
music really good people working on it
and it sounds like a fabulous show so
check it out Hulu's up here on Hulu
March 24th today's episode is also
brought to you by just Thrive let's face
it stress sucks especially when it seems
to run your life keeping you on edge and
refusing to let you relax and unwind but
here's the good news there's now a way
to beat stress before it beats up on you
just Thrive probiotic and just calm are
here to help you reclaim your health
your happiness and your peace of mind
their breakthrough probiotic formula is
clinically proven to balance your gut
this is huge because as much as 90 of
Americans have an overgrowth of bad
bacteria in their gut and studies show
that an unhealthy gut can lead to an
increase in stress hormones so not only
will just Thrive probiotic help you stay
ahead of things like gas bloat and
constipation your gut is balanced when
your gut is balanced and healthy you'll
be able to handle stress like a boss
plus their probiotic has zero filler
gluten dairy histamines and it can be
sprinkled into any food and drink so
it's the perfect probiotic for your
whole family and their new mood support
just calm you can add in for Next Level
stress busting there's big buzz around
just calm and that's because this
product is scientifically proven to
soothe everyday stress encourage a
steady and balanced mood improve
alertness and focus and even help you
get better sleep so up your Wellness
game and beat the bloat digestive issues
and stress with just Thrive and right
now when you go to Just thrive.com and
use promo code toast you can get 20 off
a 90-day bottle of just Thrive probiotic
and the just com that's like getting a
month for free check out all their
research back products for optimal gut
and immune Health again use promo code
toast for 20 off a 90-day bottle of just
Thrive probiotic and just calm that
website is just thrivehealth.com promo
code toast thank you you're welcome our
next story
Bad Bunny seemingly disses Kendall's ex
Devin Booker on new song yeah Bad Bunny
is turning heads with his latest lyrics
as some think his feature on the track
Coco Chanel doubles as a disc towards
Kendall's ex Devin Booker the new song
from Eladio carrion features an
appearance from uh Bad Bunny and it he
makes an alleged reference to the
Phoenix Suns he said they sing in
Spanish but translated it means I'm not
bad baby that's a gimmick but the sun in
Puerto Rico is hotter than in Phoenix
she knows it
okay like also I think people are like
reading into stuff but like that's hella
direct like Phoenix is pretty specific
and then especially for somebody who
does Latin music like right it's even a
song like about America right elsewhere
in the song he uh wraps that scorpio
women are dangerous and Kendall is a
Scorpio see you know what that could be
a coincidence like maybe he you know
just like score maybe he's really into
horoscopes but the other one feels like
a really
um really targeted targeted but at the
same time they really haven't been
dating for that long and like songs take
so long to produce that the timeline
like doesn't add up for me unless
they've been dating for a lot longer
than we know and they've only started to
give us crumbs recently perhaps and I
will say the last time we spoke about
Bad Bunny and Kendall how like we were
so here for it our Hispanic toasters
made themselves known and they said they
do not support this relationship so and
they didn't really give me a reason that
like made me
stop liking them but I respect your
decision
oh she snoozed on it I agree Bad Bunny
fans are like not here for it they don't
think that this is a good couple I think
it's probably based on
his personality and like hers just not
not seeming like they would
Jive or it's just based on like a
protectiveness I feel like that happens
a lot like whenever there's like a major
male star the female fans don't like the
girlfriend for whatever reason and
whatever whether they're valid or not
it's really just rooted in like this
protectiveness and almost like a
territorialism yes also it's worth
noting it Devin Booker might have
responded to this he did situation
because he posted on Instagram in a
comment um that has since been deleted
and it said he's worried about another
Caps man again
is he calling Bad Bunny gay
is that what that meant I don't know
wait he's worried about another man
again again
it sounds like these two have history by
the way because I don't even know what
the [__] you're talking about right and
then it was deleted also this line in
People Magazine made me laugh
Reps for Bad Bunny Jenner and Booker and
the sun's organization did not
immediately respond to people's requests
for comment wait you're telling me that
the Phoenix Sun did not respond to their
request for another for comment could
you imagine that's shocking
I can't believe they even like wrote
that that's like embarrassing like
admitted that they reached out that's an
embarrassing email to write to the
Phoenix Suns like do you have any
commentary on this lyric because Bad
Bunny spoke about the city the sun in
Phoenix oh also like we didn't even put
together that they're called the Phoenix
Suns and he's talking about the strength
of the Phoenix Sun oh by the way it's
100 about Devin Booker honestly it's
like pretty good line like considering
everything it's a it's a decent burn
it's a sick burn wait can we just talk
one more time trying to figure out what
Devin Booker meant like I'm just unclear
he's worried about another man again
Finn's been circulating screenshots that
show analogly to comment from his
Instagram
apparently in response to the lyrics per
the U.S sun he worried about another man
again or is he calling Kendall gay
is somebody being called Gay like I'm so
confused honestly if anybody has any
thoughts on like what this could
translate to like feel free to drop a
comment on YouTube I'm hella confused
yes please I feel like context we're
missing I feel like we're dumb you know
it's like there's something it's like
when you're looking for the grapes and
they're like right in front of you like
what or like there's just like history
that we don't know but like what again
and why is man in caps yeah no the man
is giving gay Vibes yeah yeah but I'm
not sure
but maybe I'm just jumping today like
maybe you are jumping today
I need I'm like this is I feel like
found in me sometimes I just wish people
would be as as explicit as Shawn Mendes
yeah or as law Roach
true I just I it feels like I'm hearing
a sentence in English and it sounds like
French like and I'm like what hold on
we'll do it one more time yeah he
worried okay
no no but maybe in past tense he worried
about another man again
no no it's it's definitely like he's
worried but it's like you know shortened
for internet lingo he's worried you
don't think in the past he worried about
another man again
no no but I liked that that you know
that was really creative way of thinking
but read it one more time is he calling
Kendall a cheater
he worried about another no but the man
is caps he's worried about another man
again
I really you know when you start to say
a word so much it starts to not sound
like English like garage garage this
sentence is not making sense to me it's
not English
he worried about another man again no
but you are also like being weird with
this hey Claudia I'm gonna I just like I
want to just text you so you can see it
in plain text he's worried about another
man again
we're making I'm going to the Sun
article to see if there's anything else
was there typo
his word okay the caption on the post
that he commented on read oh context
more information Bad Bunny just sent
some subliminals to Devin Booker on his
version on Coco Chanel do you all think
he wants everyone to know he's dating
Kendall Jenner again now
um
he worried about another man again
it sounds like
like feels like now for another a second
time like bad bunnies with a woman and
he's like worried about the woman's
ex-boyfriend yeah yeah agreed he's
basically calling Bad Bunny like a loser
yeah like
yeah no he's still worried about me
again because he has a pattern of doing
this like focusing on another man like
and he's so worried and he's like focus
on the girl yeah yeah yeah it's kind of
a good read yeah yeah it just requires
he's worried about another man again
it's like worry about your woman oh my
God yes that's why man is capital we
figured it out we cracked the code
context is key context is key
con Texas key okay I'm glad we went over
to the sun me too
to solve this riddle yeah it's kind of
like losery a Bad Bunny like what are
you writing lyrics about your girl's
X-Man like yes on the fact that you got
the girl yeah like Kendall's waiting for
you but this definitely like in my
opinion like UPS Kendall's cool Factor
like like that two major like manly men
are like getting Instagram drama for her
like I kind of love it that another man
is worried about her again right again
a man
man okay great now I feel really good
about going into the fifth and final
story I feel like thus far you know
every story has really kind of come full
circle this is like a very healing
episode we're reaching understanding yes
it's nice it is nice well I feel like
more often than not we're left with so
many questions
I hope that in this Fifth and final
story it will leave us with a place of
understanding okay let's see
the family of Stephen Smith who was
found dead near Alex Murdoch's home
raises money to exhume his body that's
like it's not about the fact that it was
near the home
oh I didn't even realize they were they
that they needed money I'll [__]
donate yeah yeah the body of a South
Carolina teen who mysteriously died near
the home of Alex Murda though that's not
like why they're all connected but okay
we'll be like the whole town is near the
home of Alex Murdo it's a small town
right no it's like this guy was you know
allegedly Buster murdo's gay lover and
he was all over the crime scene and all
over the police reports and like all the
rumors in town where that like I started
something to do this it had nothing to
do with like being near the home of Alex
Murdoch also then call it Buster's house
because like right this is a buster Ting
all right we're busting this case wide
open his body will be exhumed in a new
autopsy will be conducted they never
conducted an autopsy the first time
because they just kept saying it was a
hit and run hit a road crash and it was
nothing of the sort but if you
categorize it as such like then there's
no autopsy the family of Steven Smith
announced in a GoFundMe on Thursday that
they have raised enough money to exhume
his body for an independent autopsy his
2015 death investigation was reopened
after the murders of Maggie and Paul
Murdo in 2021 Smith was found dead on
Sandy Run Road in rural Hampton County a
short distance from the Murda State his
death was originally classified as a hit
and run but the investigation was
reopened in 2021 after Maggie and Paul's
bodies were found however the
authorities have not called his death a
homicide at this time Smith's family has
long maintained that his death was not
merely a hit and run but they have never
explicitly implicated the Murdoch family
authorities have never publicly
disclosed the link between Smith and the
Murdoch family but Buster murdaugh the
surviving son of Alex murdaugh was one
of Smith's High School classmates
there's a lot of rumor innuendo
without their connection and also their
presence together that night so yeah I
think you know when you when you when
people like started to learn about the
Murdoch trial while it was going on and
watching the documentaries and everyone
was really focused on like did Alec kill
you know his wife and son one of the
real like you know collateral tragedies
of this family was the murder of Stephen
Smith who was this like young boy who
had his whole life ahead of him who was
like a real nice kid like hearing his
friends talking about him it was so sad
and how his whole death was just swept
under the rug in this town was so
horrible and so tragic and so
everyone was really focused on Paul and
Maggie
um and I get it but this was like one of
the things that Gloria too that just
never got Justice that the family
exploited and used their influence to
just
make it go away and this is like a
family who lost their son and it's so
tragic and they never got any answers so
I love that this first step is being
taken and I hope you know it had some
your bodies Decay over time and what I
learned when I was watching um
uh what was I watching were they exhumed
someone's body
[__]
oh to get DNA it was like this
documentary about
um
one of those doctors who would you know
steal people's babies and sell them to
other families whatever they were saying
how like when you exhume a body
depending on how it was embalmed in just
nature in itself and it's like 10 15
years either the body will be in perfect
condition or you will open the casket
and it will be body soup like literal
with water and dust depending on the
coffin like and you can't get anything
from it so it just depends on all these
different factors environmental and then
also how they were laid to rest what
information can you get it has only been
about five years or no when was he
killed it's now almost eight years
yeah it just depends that's so
interesting
um but I feel like even if they have a
body that they can exhume and test like
an autopsy is going to show kind of what
we already know that like it was blunt
force trauma that killed him not a hit
and run if they could collect DNA that
would be great but what I think they
really need to do is go through his cell
phone records because who did Stephen
Smith call when his car ran out of gas
yeah and I I don't really know if you
can collect DNA it's not like he was
like you know put in the casket right
after the car accident you get people
ready for a funeral you clean them you
watch them right right formaldehyde
there's not going to be Buster's DNA on
him oh you're saying they were getting
DNA from like who the genealogy and what
yeah they wanted to see if this guy was
related to these kids like that's why
they in the documentary I was watching
so I I'd have never seen I don't know if
you can you can no you can't that makes
total sense yeah um
so I wonder what they're looking for
I don't know but I they need to if
they're opening the investigation again
they need to look through the cell phone
records like they had like the murder
family friend or family lawyer tried to
reach out to Stephen's family to like
represent them they took Steve he took
Stephen's phone but all that stuff like
lives in
in the class in the cloud and also like
in uh the cell phone providers like
records yeah no you can get that [__]
you can get that [__] so if the
investigation is open I think that's the
first place to start whoever he called
that's who's
responsible we're looking at that's who
we're looking at what happened that
night seriously Justin Justice for
Steven Smith did you ever watch the HBO
Max one no but I actually did end up
hearing it was filled with more
information it was really good and I
felt like
the Netflix one really focused on
Mallory Beach which you know what
another tragedy that was swept under the
radar now we know her name but like I
understood the like the details of and
the grisly details of what happened and
who she was and who all this group of
friends was and the Netflix one they
kind of were like oh yeah and Gloria and
Steven's desks were suspicious too yeah
and watching the HBO Max one like
oh my God my heart sank for they spent a
lot of time on Steven Smith they
interviewed his family and his friends
which the Netflix one only have like one
friend of Stevens talking about it it
had a friend and I think it had um his
parents oh this one was like so much
more detailed about who Stephen was and
the grizzly details of his murder and
how the after he was
killed how they kind of passed his case
around to all these different you know
Highway patrols and it's like this and
they would set and the you know the
officers went and they were like this
isn't a hit and run and they wouldn't
take it as a homicide they wouldn't
investigate it they were like no it's a
hit and run so it's under your
jurisdiction no and the way it was in
the middle of this like Rural Road and
if it wasn't for that farmer we heard
that uh 9-1-1 call who found him that
night his body wouldn't have been
discovered for a while and the murdo's
might have been able to do something
with it like if Buster ran home and told
his grandpa so like the the little
information we have we're so even lucky
to have because that guy who called
9-1-1 yeah
and then now he was such you could hear
he was like this cute old man but to me
like that's a crime that's clearly a
homicide that could have been solved
yeah so easily if they actually cared to
solve it because Buster Murdoch is no
great genius who's gonna evade police no
when they're teenagers it's all in their
cell phones just like they're on their
salary Beach it was all on Snapchat yeah
right right right right right right and
like even you know if you if Buster
Murdoch was a under
um
a suspect then you start looking at
where his phone was that night like did
his phone ping the tower that's closest
to this location like it's it's I'm not
even like a crime girl I could tell no
you're not but the fact that they never
even questioned Buster even though the
whole town was saying we heard it has
something to do with Buster it's such a
gross like abusive power and miscarriage
of justice and like really
it's and that was my whole takeaway from
the whole case it's like I didn't know
[__] like this really happened it's like
always happening in like ABC dramas like
he runs this town it's like yeah sure no
he literally ran the town and was able
to buy you're gonna go into law
enforcement and be so easily bought into
covering up crimes you have no [__]
Scruples what are you in law enforcement
for right you get into law enforcement
because you have such a passion for
justice and for helping people and
you're gonna take this ugly [__] fire
crotch's money you loser like I have
less I have to bring redheads into it
sorry I know I just wanted to I have to
use a slur I'm sorry I just wanted to
insult it but I shouldn't have done that
because that's directly I've been
selling my pizza no I'm sorry I'm sorry
I
I should have come up with a better word
I'm sorry I'm sorry like what do we have
to do with it no for sure for sure I
I'll I won't do it again I'm sorry
you'll do better attorney Lou I'll do
better do better turdy Lou everyone
needs to do better
agreed but ex like I feel hopeful that
this autopsy might give us something to
move forward with
yeah I don't know what they're gonna
find in the autopsy but you gotta just
check the cell phones man I know it's a
step maybe like they find something in
the autopsy that Cracks the Case wide
open you can't just like the
investigation is open again no I know
you can't just like get phone records
you need like a warrant and to get a
warrant you need like actual proof
because people are entitled to privacy
but the mother Steven's mother can't get
his phone records his yes but I think
you gotta open up Busters too people
have no you start with Stevens you see
who he called and then that person is
asked for questions my my knowledge of
the law is limited here I'll be I'll be
quite transparent with everyone
yeah and where is Steven's phone
I don't know but I don't think you need
the phone like the records no but like
if Steven's mother has his phone he
could just go through his phone yeah
yeah I'm sure they have
um
family friend lawyer like wanted to take
it or yeah or it was never recovered
no it was found in his car with his
wallet or anything yeah oh wow
or no it was in his pocket and it was an
attack
it was intact in his pocket which is
also a sign that's not a hit and run
right right because you go flying
through the air when you get hit and run
and you'd land on Wednesday so I'm sure
Buster ran home to his dad was like but
he texted me and he has his phone right
and then the you know the corrupt lawyer
said oh give me Steven's phone I'll deal
with it I'll take care of it I'll take
care of it sick
um so those were that is like another
full circle story I felt like we closed
the gap on a lot of stories today yeah
no we're not it's not closed but like we
are in there we always say like we hope
for updates and here we actually got one
yeah
and we hope for more we hope for more
um that was our show great Monday
episode honestly I feel great I feel
great I feel like we avoided like
negativity as much as possible in terms
of my period yes we did did you feel
like I was short with you no okay never
I wasn't giving Shawn Mendes shortness
no no we are not dating go [__] yourself
we are not dating eat my ass [__] we
are not dating I hate Sabrina
literally
um so thank you guys so much for
listening to the toast the millennial
Morning Show where we deliver the past
five stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching this on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
podcast anywhere podcast can be found on
Spotify I just did your public radio I
already guessed all the places
and wickedly talented we are hope you
guys have a great day and we'll see you
tomorrow love ya bye